- [Instructor] A veterinarian
is studying a certain disease
that seems to be affecting male
cats more than female cats.
They obtain a random sample
of records from 500 cats.
They find 24 of the 259
male cats have the disease
while 14 of 241 female
cats have the disease.
The veterinarian uses these results
to test their null hypothesis
that the true proportion is
the same amongst the male
and female cats
versus the alternative hypothesis
that the proportion of
males who get the disease
is actually higher than
the proportion of females.
The test statistic was z is equal to 1.46
and the P-value was approximately 0.07.
That's useful.
They've done a lot of work for us.
Assume that all conditions
for inference were met.
At the alpha equals 0.10
level of significance,
is there sufficient evidence to conclude
that a larger proportion of
male cats have the disease?
So pause this video and
see if you can answer that.
All right, so remember what we
do with a significance test.
We assume our null hypothesis,
and then given,
and then with that assumption,
we look at our data
and we calculate a P-value.
We say, hey,
what is the probability of
getting the data that we did
assuming our null hypothesis is true?
And if that is lower than
our significance level,
then we reject the null hypothesis.
We say, hey,
assuming the null hypothesis,
we got a pretty unlikely event.
We reject it.
Which would suggest the alternative.
And so here our P-value is 0.07,
which is indeed less than our alpha,
which is less than our significance level.
This thing right over here is 0.10.
And so because of that,
we would reject the null hypothesis.
Reject null hypothesis.
Which would, which is,
we could say there is
sufficient evidence to conclude
that a larger proportion of
male cats have the disease.
We could say suggests the
alternative hypothesis.
And so on Econ Academy
there's some multiple
choice questions like this,
and so the choice that you would pick
might be something like,
because our P-value is less
than our significance level,
we would reject the null hypothesis,
and that would suggest the alternative.